ok
they'll do it when she comes up oh
they'll do it all right
good evening everyone thank you for
coming tonight i must say that in the
absence of our great Dean mark Wiggly
who injured his ankle and is had surgery
yesterday so I am feeling very big shoes
here especially when he's got the cast
on so but it is my great great honor and
privilege tonight to introduce Amanda
burden I'm going to read a little
official bio and then add to it a bit
Amanda M burden fa fa ICP is the chair
of the New York City Planning Commission
and director of the Department of City
Planning since her appointment by Mayor
Bloomberg in 2002 she has spearheaded
the largest planning effort in the city
since nineteen sixty one setting the
stage for sustainable development
reclaiming New York's waterfront
designing new parkland in public spaces
such as the High Line and promoting
great architecture and urban design in
all five boroughs I just wanted to add
on a personal note I had the great
privilege of being amandes Manhattan
director from 2001 to 2005 many of you
have heard about Amanda read about
Amanda I thought I should add a couple
of things that maybe are not so obvious
first of all she's the hardest worker I
think I have ever met one of the key
lessons for me and working with amanda
was the fact that she spent every hour
near as I could tell that she had free
walking every site that we were looking
at if a developer proposed something if
we were proposing something she would
walk every block we would go into a
staff meeting and she always knew more
about any given site we were talking
about than anyone on the staff and she
would say well have you been there you
stood on that block do you know what
that street corners like it was an
extraordinary working experience for me
I learned a tremendous amount I would
also say that she has the keenest design
I that I've encountered in this city
which is interesting because her formal
training from this great institution she
graduated a master's in urban planning
from here and published a thesis titled
securing a future for recycling
processing the critical link to market
development so a very broad range of
interests amanda has extraordinary
political sad
watching her negotiate with City Council
and community members and making sure
that everyone's voice feels heard is a
gift really that she brings to the table
Amanda's won numerous awards including
Nichols prize from the uli she's often
cited as one of the greatest city
planning chairs in modern history i will
tell one short story about this which is
when someone said that while you were
getting an award and i was sitting next
to joe rose Amanda's predecessor and Joe
sort of looked a little sheepish and you
were wearing this fabulous gold lamay
dress and I said don't worry Joe I'm
sure you look great in the golden may as
well right but it hard act to either
precede or follow in fact the New York
Times raved that Miss burden is leaving
an indelible legacy of how all five
boroughs will look and feel for decades
to come ladies and gentlemen I give you
Amanda burden
thank you be Sean we had incredible time
together and you'll hear a little bit
about tonight I can't tell you how
really really thrilled I am to be back
at Columbia at Avery I spent so many
incredible years here learning the craft
of City Planning and really
understanding how important that was to
the future of the city of New York so
let me take you through some of the
initiatives that we have focused on in
at New York City it's just an incredible
time to work for a mayor who cares so
much about every part of the city and
making it one of the greatest cities
really on earth now you know most of
people when people think of New York
City they think of New York skyline and
its skyscrapers and its density and it's
crowded sidewalks and it's yellow cabs
but really what New York City is it's a
patchwork of different neighborhoods
with different character and unique
distinction about different
neighborhoods and it's our topic city
planning to understand the diversity of
these neighborhoods and really respond
to communities needs and opportunities
it's also central to our focus is
economic development and making sure the
New York City is competitive on the
world stage that is very very important
to our future and it's also important
that New York present opportunities to
everybody to come here to start a
business to get a job and to climb a
little at the ladder of life and key to
our success has always been our ability
to welcome people from elsewhere and we
have to make sure that we keep those
opportunities open and growing not only
opportunities but it's very important
that we provide to New Yorkers and to
anybody who wants to come here a quality
of life in in their lives so that they
not only choose to come here but they
choose to stay here and during the past
eight years that's what we have tried to
achieve so it's not just opportunity but
it's quality of life and the reasons
that make people decide to come and stay
in the city so what we do at City to
planning is to direct development
of our business districts our
neighborhoods our industrial areas and
our waterfront and during the past eight
years we've not done that but not only
that the way we judge ourselves is how
people view their everyday lives and how
it feels essentially in the end on the
street when a project has developed and
my mentor was Holly white william h
white who wrote the organization man but
who was one of the great urban artists
of all time and he always said and I say
this often because I believe it so much
you can measure the health of a city by
the vitality of its streets and public
spaces and in fact that's how I judge
everything that we do so let me tell you
a little bit just about the history of
the development of the of the population
of New York City New York City lost an
enormous amount of its population in the
70s and the 80s but you can see on this
chart you can see the general population
growth of the country on top but look at
the trajectory of the population growth
of new york city it's just astonishing
how lucky we are because we welcome our
growth but the challenge is how to
accommodate it so we expect to grow to
9.1 million people were at 8.4 million
now by 2030 so our challenge is how do
we accommodate that growth in the city
but still keep the character of new york
city's neighborhoods in fact what I
often say is what we want to do is we
have 188 neighborhoods what we want to
do is grow but not change and always
keep the quality of life that exists in
these different neighborhoods remember
each of these neighborhoods are
completely different and our goal is to
grow to grow in place because the city's
mostly built out but to but to keep the
quality of life and that's what we've
tried to do for the past eight years and
underlying everything is a focus on
sustainability to make this city
self-sustaining
the mayor announced plan YC our
blueprint for sustainability in April of
2009 and that is how we actually measure
what we do that's about not only transit
oriented development which I'll speak
about in a minute but it's about cleaner
air cleaner water a better healthier
quality of life for New Yorkers today
and for generations to come and that is
absolutely key and they'll be plan YC
two point O coming out next April we're
lucky New York City many of its
neighborhoods are very dense around a
very strong transit infrastructure and
New Yorker can often go to ja had their
job they can actually do get their
services they can go shopping without
getting in a car they can use the way
very rich transit network and you see
even the mayor here rides the subway you
know in fact New Yorkers use two-thirds
less energy than other US residents so
in fact we are the most sustainable city
in the whole country and the mayor has
charged us to even more to reduce our
energy uses by thirty percent by 2030
but we often say that if you more people
move to New York you'd be helping the
national goal the national goal of
reducing our carbon footprint because
New York City is indeed so sustainable
and I just like this little chart
because we grew since 2000 by 355,000
people and look at the average American
uses this much carbon New Yorkers used
this much carbon so if all those people
moved elsewhere in the United States it
would be the equivalent of putting eight
hundred and sixty-six thousand cars on
the road so that's that's why it's good
to move to New York move to New York
City so what we have done over the past
eight years is to actually eight and a
half years is to reshape the land use
blueprint of the city so that remembered
that many of you know that the zoning
had not been looked at in the city since
nineteen sixty one so where you could
develop was often in auto dependent
neighbor
hoods and growth was hot growth was
happening in the wrong places so what we
did is very logical it was we didn't
call it transit oriented growth it was
to steer all development around our mass
transit network we have a very strong
mass transit network and to direct
development away from auto dependent
areas right now we are do we judge also
by how warehousing permits are right now
eighty-seven percent of housing permits
are within a ten-minute walk of a subway
the goal is by 2030 to have 95% within
10 min walk of the subway so we've
essentially reshaped the as I say the
land use blueprint of the city we have
taken through the all the way through
the public process 104 rezoning these
are small rezonings they're usually
hundred blocks right now we're about to
take South Jamaica 520 block so you do
these in large chunks we have now rezone
one-fifth of the city 9000 block so this
is really we've set the blueprint for
generations to come so that we are one
of the most sustainable most most
sustainable cities in the country and
that and not in that effort will
continue the mayor said from the very
start of this administration that he
wanted economic development in all five
boroughs he wanted regional business
district that's business districts with
both housing and office space in each
one of the borough's because that
creates jobs and housing and economic
investment each of these regional
business or central business hubs is
centered around mass transit
infrastructure so what we have done is
look for opportunities to reshape
underutilized areas into thriving
centers of economic activity and
investment each one is different the
mayor said being a good businessman
create a different product for different
customers so you see lower Manhattan is
very close to downtown Brooklyn downtown
Brooklyn be a very good place for back
office
it relates to lower Manhattan Long
Island City with midtown etc so this
became kind of our focus in creating
these business districts we started of
course with lower Manhattan after nine
eleven this was a focus of the
administration and the focus of this
whole cities to rebuild confidence in
the city and its future now you look at
lower Manhattan doesn't this look like
one of the most gorgeous fabulous places
on earth it has water on three sides
incredible architectures but the truth
is even before nine eleven lower
Manhattan was suffering it was competing
with midtown and for a city that never
sleeps lower Manhattan went to bed
promptly at five o'clock so we changed
incentives and zoning to incentive I for
a residential development and now lower
Manhattan is a thriving center with
schools and residents and cultural
institutions and restaurants all of
these things that didn't happen but
after nine eleven as you may know Laura
Manhattan was putting was given the
charge of lower Manhattan was given over
the state city didn't really have a role
in lower Manhattan but we worked very
closely with the lower Manhattan
Development Corporation to make sure
that the World Trade Center site was
integrated into the street network of
Laura Manhattan and we worked with them
to try to integrate all the very
separate neighborhoods of Chinatown and
the financial district & Battery Park
City to try to knit this as one
community but we were really worried
about the financial district because the
financial district was really so fragile
and that is a key component of our
economy we get so much of our taxes from
the financial industry that was
important to protect it and if you see
the RN square down there where it says
Hanover Square that's the financial
district and it essentially was cut off
from the waterfront it's really no
amenity whatsoever impossible to get to
battery park city and the water's edge
along north and south of the South
Street Seaport was miserable absolutely
miserable so it's totally landlocked the
financial district so we design a new
waterfront
and we went to lower Manhattan
Development Corporation and they gave us
a large this off-site ground of 150
million dollars and bishan worked on
closely on this as well it's going to be
one of the most spectacular waterfronts
in the city and will rival public space
like as fabulous as the High Line will
have a new pier a double level pier it
will have get down sits in construction
right now be open next year at first
piece of it and a spectacular new
waterfront for the city for the
financial district for the new families
that live there and for tourists so all
always we try to invest in public
infrastructure in public open space
because we realize this raises the value
and changes the perception of an area so
we're very excited about this almost at
the same time a little bit later we
focused on we call the Hudson Yards on
the west side our financial district our
main financial district is midtown that
is where our revenue and our jobs come
from when the mayor took office there
was only one large floorplate office
building for a headquarters to locate
and it was taken by Bank of America that
was it now you can see what's owning
does i love us i love the photograph
because all the west side you see the
circle that's Madison Square Garden so
everything west of that was zoned for
exclusively industrial use essentially
killing killing what we love about
midtown were like the density we like to
height we like the energy we like all
that and there was no way for a midtown
business district to expand so instead
of just sewing at blanket zoning of a
commercial zone we're together and
bishan with the master of this we
created an urban design master plan and
this included the office buildings large
floor plate office buildings are in the
light blue residential is in brown this
mixed-use new neighborhood high-density
very very high density because that's
what we need and that's what we want
threaded through with a whole network of
public open space and this provide would
provide a new future it's a huge 24
million square feet of office space 12 /
20 525,000 to 12,500 new residential you
it's and that's not even counting the
eastern and western rail yards now what
the difference in the value between the
industrial the manufacturing zoning and
the new zoning was enough to leverage
the money to pay for the extension of
the number seven line two billion
dollars so this is this actually sets
the future for the website because after
you actually invest in infrastructure
transit infrastructure development
follows it's on time on budget this is
the boring machine that went in and I I
believed 2012 that it will actually open
for public use but this is a tremendous
addition to the west side a I love this
rendering I call it God shining down on
hudson yards but you could actually see
the east side and the west side merge
into one vibrant dense neighborhood and
there's many many projects already under
construction this is a project which has
not happened yet it's one of the most
important things i'll take this is a
picture of penn station in its glorious
all days at what used to be when you
arrived in manhattan this is how you
used to arrive like a prince now you
scurry in like a little furry rat but
the when we did the Hudson Yards owning
this this is Madison Square Garden the
circle there and to left of it is the
Farley office building this is a great
the greatest place for transit oriented
development in the entire city so when
we so we saw in the Hudson Yards we
allowed 5.4 million square feet to land
on this site as we examine this will
work very closely again Busan wearing
another one of his hats to try to
develop on the site it became very
complicated to build towers right on the
site because you have trained
infrastructure and the trains have to
keep going we have it city palliat
planning created an entire transfer
district let me see if it'll just come
up there and we've studied every single
site around Madison Square Garden
because this is the place to transform
Midtown also in addition to the Hudson
Yards you have the best transit
infrastructure you have four different
railroads going of the subway and there
were three different railroads all in
one place we've studied every site
to accept 5.4 million and more on this
site and we're counting on Bichon to
figure out how to make this happen
because it's very important to the
future of the city so let me talk to you
a little bit about some of the other
business districts I won't go through
all of them but i'll talk about downtown
brooklyn for just a minute for a couple
of reasons like all the other business
districts that i mentioned they are
focused around transit infrastructure
downtown Brooklyn was a very under soon
but it was a great Center both for
academic institutions cultural
institutions for ban and also Metro Tech
was an existing business district and
then fabulous neighborhoods have Boerum
Hill Brooklyn Heights and Fort Greene
but totally under under sound great
opportunity here for development so I
showing you this because what we did was
we created again an urban design master
plan and we began to use this technique
of three-dimensional images to nada to
give some sense of predictability of
what might happen we could see at a city
planning what the zoning would look like
but it was a very important
communicative tool to work with
communities because remember none of our
plans are worth anything unless they get
adopted by the community the borough
president and finally by the city
council so actually building this
consensus is absolutely critical
essential you can't do anything without
it and the key tool was using this
three-dimensional master plan in this
particular one of the office building in
blue residential apartment buildings in
red and trendy community could see how
this would transition down into the
existing low scale of the neighborhoods
and I'll just show you the next slide
this is what we used to do this is all
we showed a community when we resolve
them this in fact is the zoning for
downtown Brooklyn but if you go to
community say you are going to have c64
not in a million years would they accept
that so we went back and used this use
this tool now all of this was focused on
Flatbush Avenue
and have the high density around
Flatbush Avenue in Metro tech and again
as I mentioned always to invest our
scarce public funds in the streetscape
and flatbush avenue as you might have
noticed under construction it would look
like this it will finally become a
gateway to downtown Brooklyn and really
change the whole perception of the area
the MTA is investing in the J Street
Station and this is this actually is
rezoning has now catalyzed 23 really
huge development projects which is
absolutely key to building not only
office but residential most of this is
residential and the goal again is always
to create great places and that is
always our goal I'm next almost at the
same time we focused on one of the most
famous streets in the world 125th 125th
street is the center of african-american
history and culture has incredible
institutions of the Apollo and the lenox
lounge but the low density on 125th
student had really prevented a critical
mass of developing on 125 feet and these
institutions were beginning to die
because of lack of density so all of
that incredible history over the Apollo
and these incredible theaters and the
nightlife in the history of Malcolm X
and in the density of these sidewalks
and the magic of 125th street was really
kind of withering away and so we did a
very complicated rezoning what a
rezoning plan looks like and it had
multiple goals one was to preserve the
character of some of the brownstones ice
in yellow on 125th Street to catalyze
density in the in the pink areas around
the mass transit hubs but the goal of
125 feet was about the entertainment and
the cultural heritage of of this
incredible center of
african heritage and so we use zoning to
achieve those goals this looks like this
is what we use the zoning diagram but
this tells you what we did we required
five percent of every development to
have an entertainment use we created a
bonus for creation of an arts venue
either for visual arts or performance
arts as we've never done this before we
prohibited banks from having banks from
having more than 25 foot frontage
anywhere on 120 50 fine to have their
retail operations on the second floor so
all of this together gives you diverse
retail will get will give when market
comes back the critical mass of both
entertainment arts and entertainment on
125th Street to really make it what it
is promise always has been and what it
was in the past and we're really really
excited about you can see a lot of a lot
of bacon sites just poised to develop
and hotels are beginning and it will
really take off as it's incredible
exciting place to go in the day and in
the night time I'm unabashed it saying
that the High Line is my favorite
project that I ever worked on I saw this
incredible abandoned elevator rail line
before I got this job and I said I can't
help you have no power but I am totally
in love with this project this line RINs
runs for twenty two blocks a mile in
half you can walk on it without coming
in touch with a single single vehicle it
was just absolutely magical and I felt
madly in love with it and really knew
right then that it could be the defining
feature of a new neighborhood and I
don't know if you remember that
neighborhood was really just filled with
car washes and car repair pets
incredible art gallery district and that
needed to be saved was also an
opportunity to provide housing and
affordable housing for New York however
the previous administration really
really hated it and I thought it should
come down they thought it was a blinding
influence on the on the community it was
a rusty old thing
and just get rid of it we developed a
master plan VaShawn working very very
very closely with me and as we began to
let me just backtrack for a moment the
Highline was owned by the federal
government and CSX was the railroad in
charge of it and they said we will not
transfer this to the city and when I
when I was appointed to this and begin
my number one project to get it done we
will not transfer the High Line to the
city unless every single property owner
signs on well there were 38 property
owners who did not want the line and as
we began to talk to them we found that
they were property owners who owned land
underneath and adjacent to the High Line
so again beside us very much of a theme
in this dog but Dashon came up with a
old tried-and-true tool that we use
which is transfer of development rights
but it made all the difference see the
blue box that's properties who
underneath and adjacent to the high line
by creating an entire special district
and a transfer mechanism where anybody
in the owned land in that blue box could
transfer their air rights to their
property rights to anybody who owned
anybody who owned land on the avenues
either tenth or eleventh Avenue we
capped heights but within that high we
reduce the height unless you bought the
property rights from the from those
property owners they were thrilled they
signed on 38 property owners you know
the rest is history we created one of
the most extraordinary parks in the
world and you know it's been opened
since june 2009 and we've had
3.5 million visitors and so it's become
one of the unique destinations in the
world and great for tourism with New
York City has reached 47 47 and a half
million visitors this year have come to
New York City and haven't all visit the
High Line but it's really great and
there was there was a significant public
investment in this but it triggered 37
development projects in there 34
actually projects that are actually
going forward in this area and some of
the greatest architects in the world I
just clamoring to build here so it's
been not only a incredible success in
terms of public amenity but in terms of
economic investment it has really worked
so investment of public space really
does pay off and it's our going to be
opening the next section in the spring
of next year very excited about that and
as you can see these views are
absolutely great you have a frank frank
gehry Jean Nouvel Annabelle cell door of
sugar robe on all in one place one of
the most complicated and difficult
rezoning in the past eight years it's
been Coney Island now there was no way
that Mayor Bloomberg would lose Coney
Island on his watch Coney Island is
beloved not only by New Yorkers but from
people all over the world Coney Island
means so much to people about what you
can do when you come to New York or just
a little bit of money you can go to
Coney Island get hot though go to the
beach go on a ride Coney Island provided
just some very symbolic something very
symbolic to people all over the world
but it was dying the ride cymbal
purchased by developer one vacant lot
after another was replacing the rides
and it was going to lose its sense of
what it always had been to everybody and
so we said this is time to reclaim the
mantle of Coney Island as the most the
greatest open okay then this is how
we're Excel Coney Island greatest open
affordable and accessible urban
amusement park
in the entire world and this is how this
is really and look at the connection
between the beach and the boardwalk and
the rides and you know this is what this
is what it will become so we created a
comprehensive plan and there was a lot
of debate about what it should be should
the ride to be open and closed whatever
because the goal was to create a
year-round amusement park Lee wouldn't
close down in the summer Coney Island
just closing down now it really should
go all year round only way you can do
that is to have some enclosed and open
rides and so I said like you know like
tunnel of love that's the perfect
perfect enclosed ride and we went back
and looked at the historic uses and this
is how it was a steeplechase and
everything else there was a mix always
this mixed mixed diversity but we knew
that the open amusements were very
important so we tried to combine all of
these goals and this is I don't have a
pointer here but just on the bottom of
the slide that is the open amusement
area and we mapped it as parkland and
those who are your planners know if you
map something as parkland it's very hard
to undo so the open rides are preserved
almost a perpetuity unless you go to the
state legislature but the rest of the
area in blue is the end is the amusement
and entertainment district so it's a
27-acre amusement and entertainment
district with open and enclosed rides
but the lower part is the open amusement
park 12 acres which really keeps that
open connection to the boardwalk as well
now Coney islands one of the poorest
neighborhoods in the city it has huge
unemployment and almost all the housing
is public housing so it's very important
to create a mix of housing they're both
open and affordable housing outside of
the amusement area because it's really a
conflict there so north of surf avenue
and west of the baseball stadium the
cyclone stadium is housing and the
Restless amusement district we have a
transitional amusement park there now as
you probably know and while we rebuild
the streets because there's actually
below sea level so actually we have to
rebuild the streets because of sea level
rise and keeping them out of the storm
surge area but this is one of the
greatest opportunity
these in the city and to show you some
images of them this is what the Bowery
look like we used images actually to
sell these things a million people used
to come to Coney Island the summer
weekend this is how we see it keeping
all this diversity but keeping the low
scale very important this is how the
boardwalk looks now this is how it can
look in the future it is doing to be
spectacular and again one of the great
places in the city so we just love love
love this project New York is in fact a
collection of grade places each of its
neighborhoods are different each of its
neighborhoods have have the potential to
be fantastic as part of all of our
rezoning we try to balance preservation
and growth these are the brownstones in
bedford-stuyvesant we'd grow along
Fulton Street where there's transit we
preserve the brownstones in other areas
where there's not mass transit we really
try to preserve those characters so we
are committed to maintaining the
diversity of the city and and end
growing wherever we can in those areas
where we can't grow such as these very
suburban neighborhoods of laurelton and
rosedale Bayside and each of these
neighborhoods we have to do we want to
preserve their character and not allow
them to grow and by doing that we
actually give some predictability we
probably provide different options for
different kinds of housing we give
predictability to both people who live
there and to the development community
and most importantly we grow in the
right places so transit oriented growth
is what we do so transit-oriented growth
is centered around our great mass
transit system we're growing at second
Avenue seventh Avenue Line and we have
the most fantastic transportation
Commissioner that we've ever had in the
city two Nets I takan and she is doing
everything she can to get people out of
their cars or provide different options
alternatives to automobile use is the
best way to say it so people have to use
their car less so she this is bus rapid
transit on
up in fordham Fordham Road and she's
just introduced on first and second
Avenue I think only like a week ago ten
days ago she has laid 200 miles of bike
lanes in the city just remarkable and
the bike lanes are safe so it's much
more safe for people to bike in New York
on our part we found that people were
not used often the biggest impediment to
using it to using your bike was he
didn't have a safe place to park it
either at work or at home and so we have
passed legislation to require secure
bike parking in every new residential
and commercial building so that will
make a big difference as new buildings
go up as well car share very important
most car share we didn't anticipate car
sharing the zoning so car share was
illegal till about two weeks ago and now
is legal in many of the parking garages
in the city now it passes through the
City Council so it's legal for car share
companies to put their cars in any
garage in the city and as you know car
share means you don't only have to drive
when you need to drive you don't have to
own a car and pay insurance etc again
another option to to owning a car we
actually found we did our research that
people who belong to car share company
actually either do not buy a car or give
up their car so it's really important
and make a tremendous difference in
automobile use in the city of course the
best alternative to automobile EOS is
walking so we really really really focus
on enhancing the pedestrian environment
so we also now require street trees and
every new developments tree trees are
important also for cooling mitigating
the heat island effect and capturing
rainwater etc so you'll see trees and
mayor's pledge to plant a million trees
by 2012 and we also require the planting
of front yards okay you wouldn't think
this is a big thing but in these
suburban neighborhoods they are
concreting over their front yards which
can cause flooding in their basements in
the sewer system so by this green
infrastructure planting front yards you
actually enhance the pedestrian
environment it's also very good for our
sewer systems parking lots
not a lot anymore not allowed oceans of
asphalt we have required in a large
parking lot so there be bioswales it
catches the rainwater canopy trees again
cool mitigate the heat island effect and
also it's much more beautiful so this is
how parking lots will look in the future
and one of the first things we did was I
love sidewalk cafes but this is just a
great way to enhance sidewalk life and
during the summer months really has
transformed the city it's one of the
most difficult very zonings to do
everybody was mad but it really changes
the city and you see them all over the
place but that wasn't legal before this
administration so let me also mentioned
this is very important you know great
architecture it's important it's
important to keep the city young and
dynamic and competitive so we have
really raised the bar for great
architecture because we are competitive
city where a global city and
architecture helps us compete and you've
seen the North the Norman Foster Hearst
building incredible Diller Scofidio
alice tully hall as a pot is building
the great new museum sauna got the
pritzker prize this year and tom maine's
great engineering building this is
important to the city so ever we can
raise the bar for architecture we do but
not only great architecture high quality
design and public spaces and design
excellence is very important for our
city to remain competitive but it's not
just cultural institutions or academic
institutions it's every building these
are low-income residential buildings in
the Bronx low-income and they look great
great architecture gives sense of pride
of place and value makes people want to
stay there makes people want to invest
and so everywhere the bar for
architecture is raised and it makes an
enormous difference in this city so our
idea we've been focused on is you know
complete neighborhoods neighborhoods
that give you in the same place housing
jobs retail open space a very important
part of that is affordable housing so
the inclusionary housing program is in a
key part of all of our
theres and that's to provide a boat it
gives a bonus for affordable housing
within a height limit and that's either
for rental housing or now for
homeownership housing for low-income
affordable housing in all of these
districts has been a very important part
of making sure that New York is a
equitable City as far as equitable City
it's important everybody in the city
have access to fresh food and you
wouldn't think that was a big deal but
it's a big deal we found supermarkets
for closing all over the city and
working with Tom Frieden the health
commissioner and former health
commissioner we found that the where
their supermarkets had closed or
neighborhood grocery stores to be more
exact there were high in cities high
incidences of diabetes and obesity in
fact they were ravaged by these two
diet-related diseases so we created a
program which is called fresh and it's
those initials stand for something which
gives both financial and Zoning
incentives for the creation of a
neighborhood grocery store only past one
year ago we have three in the Bronx
created by fresh very important for New
Yorkers for our health and also because
in neighborhood grocery store you can
actually build a community around the
neighborhood grocery store very
important planning component and public
open space even these small public
spaces which happened to me my
particular passion because Holly white
focused on them so much if there was so
well designed so that they're inviting
and well used that means providing
plenty plentiful seating and shade and
opportunity different opportunities and
reasons to come each of these can add up
to make a huge difference in the city
and make it much more livable because
free we have a very dense City and these
provide refuge for just refuse or for
sociability our current focus now and is
on sustainable buildings I told you that
you know we used two thirds less energy
than the rest of the country but what we
do use eighty percent is used by our
buildings and so we really have to look
at making our buildings more
energy-efficient so we're looking very
hard at the zoning
seeing where our zoning actually creates
impediments to energy efficiency and
energy generation so things like solar
panels or solar shades shades coming up
or even wind turbines we want to make
sure that those are we allow those
rooftop obstructions our goal is to
create you know is to emulate the bank
of america which is the building on the
left of the slide has no parking it
generates its own energy and it looks
gorgeous so it really provides a kind of
an ideal so we are going to be looking
at this very very closely in the future
as part of plan YC 2.0 what we're
focusing on now as well almost all our
energy is focused on the new
comprehensive waterfront plan for the
city we released our recommendations
have been working for a whole year
analyzing every reach of the city's
waterfront 540 miles of waterfront and
we released our recommendations have
after having a bunch of workshops all
over the city and I the the proposals
for the future really take into
consideration the fact that the
waterfront has changed a great deal
since our first plan in 1992 much more
public access new 50 miles of access our
ports are stronger and people are really
engaging with the water more than they
ever have before but in this new new
environment of engaging the water there
are many conflicts that we have to deal
with we have a port of and we have to
strengthen our port and a maritime
industry at the same time as we have to
provide housing for New Yorkers we have
to protect our wetlands and our habitats
and our waterways at the same time as we
provide this infrastructure that keep
the city running we have to use our
water our water for transportation both
for freight and passenger movement at
the same time as we allow people to use
with cool human-powered boating kayaking
and rowing and in recreational boats
really really want that and in fact we
found that people know that they're at
the edge of the water New Yorkers want
to get onto and into the water they are
passionate about the water and that is
what our plan is going to be addressing
in fact the water should be part of New
Yorkers everyday life recall the water
and the waterways are six Varo because
the water should command as much
attention in planning as we now give to
the land and if the water becomes that
part of our everyday life and we
understand that it's no longer the land
that shapes our water but it's really
the water of its shapes and land that
the water becomes a central to New
York's identity and as New York embraces
the water as its central identity then
we believe it will continue to be the
greatest city in the world and I thank
you so much
wow it's unbelievable I mean you know
people used to think the Department of
City Planning was just about zoning it's
really extraordinary class these are on
right so we wanted to do some Q&A and I
thought I'd kick it off with a couple of
questions so you describe this
extraordinarily comprehensive plan but
now that the mayor has this new
leadership team in place in City Hall is
there are there three four projects that
are becoming the sort of defining
initiatives for the third term of the
Bloomberg administration well I will we
have two new deputy actually have three
new deputy mayors Howard Wolfson Stephen
Goldsmith from houston mayor of
Indianapolis and Bob steel has a broad
portfolio and I think that they are
going to be developing their own agenda
which will be revealed within the next
month or so of what and that will be
part of our identified for speaking for
City Planning I think you saw some of
the priorities that we have certainly
the waterfront plan is absolutely key to
the future of the city a broad
sustainability agenda it's not it's not
just buildings but it's continuing with
transit oriented development and we just
were awarded consortium the sustainable
community grants from HUD a 3.5 million
dollars to the city and we formed a
consortium with Connecticut cities and
cities first regional effort and we're
looking at creating transit oriented
development around the Metro North lines
in the Bronx and also in East New York
these are going to be models of
sustainable communities and it's
tremendous to get that kind of
recognition from from the federal
government so its sustainability and
it's the waterfront and signature public
open space will be very much part of our
agenda so it's the second second and
third phases of the High Line and it's
the what we call the lower the East the
east river esplanade we call east river
esplanade south and I think that's part
of the legacy of the administration is
it's amazing it's interesting the
transit oriented density in terms of its
you know thinking about it regionally
help you when when you talk about the
number of sort of up zonings that have
been done in Manhattan versus that the
sort of imperative for neighborhood
protection and in a lot of brooklyn and
queens and staten island do you feel
like there are ever conflicts in terms
of how much development capacity we
could generate along say Queens
Boulevard where for subway lines run or
you know parts of the borough's it
actually could take a lot of density but
maybe you have to keep the density a
certain cap because of neighborhood
preservation we're very mindful that we
still as we say we were going to grow by
1.1 million New Yorkers and I was
starting an administration we've already
added almost 400,000 we actually have
700,000 to accommodate and that we still
need to grow by about 200 over 200,000
units and we're very conscious that we
have to grow wherever we can grow but we
actually know that we can do that
because we have accommodated already
several hundred thousand units in just
this administration so we only have to
do about 125 per year so answer to your
question very still is we still have
such a great transit infrastructure that
we can grow at those densities but as
you know as you said I walk every
neighborhood and there's just so much
density that can be stomach without
destroying the qualities of a
neighborhood that brought people there
in the first place right now in the
Bronx we're rezoning all along Webster
Avenue and that can take some density
but probably not more than ten stories
doesn't seem like much in manhattan by
the Webster Avenue that's just about as
much as you can take on Third Avenue
north of Fordham Road most you can
really take us but eight stories there
may be a little bit more and so it's
really a judgment of the community we
always push the envelope but you're not
going to get it passed so everywhere we
everywhere we look at up zoning it
really has to reflect the innate nature
of that community and they can tell if
you haven't walked it you don't
understand it so we're always pushing
the envelope so to incentivize
investment but not to destroy the
community so does the 9.1 million that
2030 represent a sort of overall cap for
New York City do you think we can to get
faster right I mean I mean you know it's
funny it's terrible door is closed yeah
I mean it's you know for some people a
million more people sounds like a lot
but in another way when you look at
cities growing around the war
old and the rapid organization that's
going I mean is that enough to keep us
competitive should we know by 2050 we
could actually accommodate 12 million
I'm making up numbers now but it just is
that a cap as the nine point one of I
mean um you know it's a you know you
know when you see it I think we can
actually accommodate more growth without
and I say this we grow but not change I
always say that because if people like
up to here with development they feel
like the city isn't the city they
recognize then we've lost everything so
I don't think you know until you get
closer to their whether you have to put
more clamps on on development for a long
way from there now and we want to always
have the city feel like a place that you
can come to and that you can you know
invest in and that it's always always
welcomed or i mean it's it's a
population flow so interesting and now
we always have like 100 people 100
thousand people arriving a hundred
thousand people leaving and there's this
incredible dynamic mix and we always
want that to happen but New York has to
be recognizable and I think the great
thing that's happened over the past
eight years is that all neighborhoods of
the city are like equally attractive
mean people are now living in
neighborhoods that eight years ago they
wouldn't have even known the name of
Norwood bedford park you know each of
these neighborhoods are really not only
unique but they're incredibly desirable
because they have this different
character and we can't destroy nobody
who comes in our place to historic so
it's really important to leave that
legacy so how it will feel at 9.9
million people you know i don't know we
use Shaun Donovan used to talk about the
fact that that the pressure is
unaffordable housing are
so great because we are sort of almost
victims of our own success there we are
creating so many great neighborhoods for
people to live in that it actually
pushes prices up everywhere and it's
hard to actually talk about transit
oriented development because in a city
like ours anything that's near transit
is so expensive for average people to
afford to live in is it well also you
know supply should write actually have
an effect on prices so the more supply
you actually have on the market it
should help help prices it doesn't seem
to have changed very much but people are
finding new neighborhoods you just
follow the l line and yelled sudden
bushwick no but it would have been
living every now we're slipping in
bushwick so each of these neighborhoods
people are moving to because they find
them morphol they find them affordable
and so the Bronx will be the next borrow
that would be the most desirable borough
to them and very excited because it's
unique and has great transit lines ok
one more question I'll turn it over to
the hundreds of people I'm sure each and
gas questions which is um and the
question is not were you the swimmer in
the photograph of Hungary no
the you mentioned LMDC with the World
Trade Center site and Moynihan station
which is obviously very heavily
influenced by the state because of sort
of Home Rule issues and things that
happened in New York in the 70s and even
before have we seated too much control
to the state is it a frustrating thing
to have to know that they're big chunks
of City Planning that happened at
actually aren't in control of the city
whether it's the MTA or you know all
sorts of the Trade Center site whatever
you want to think about is that is that
something we just have to live with oh I
was gonna say yes you are the question
yes do I have a problem with it yet
because we really believe that projects
are much better with public input that's
not saying that really really really
believe that and going through that
laborious process that iterative process
of what we call you lurve which is the
uniform land use review procedure always
without any question makes a better
product and it's born into and the
community knows their community much
better than like state agency just
coming in outer from outer space and so
it really benefit projects would always
be much better than that on the other
hand the state owns that land so they
have a rightful interest in that land
but the projects aren't as good as they
could be if there were significant over
a long period of time and we consider
that several year time to really
fine-tune projects so it really benefits
the community and it's better integrated
with it okay I'm sure there are many
questions in the audience sir from the
back and can I ask if you're from the
media if you could identify yourself as
such I'd appreciate it no I'm not for
the medium in alumni does it general
good to identify yourself in any case
sir then I do my name is Juan Polanco am
an architect planner Oh product of
Columbia you mentioned me that you're
the plan is giving away of importance to
revival revitalizing the waterways of
New York is a sixth borough for me that
must include by necessity at creating
revitalizing and creating new fairy
lines between the various boroughs from
outlying regions well the area of
Jamaica Bay fort rockaway comes to mind
as a place that could really be helped
big deal if there were a trunk line
ferry that connected with Manhattan with
other areas is that part of your plan
what is being done to foster more growth
of of these alternate forms of
transportation that really a very
significant for making people inhabit
the coastlines much more than they do
now knitting our burros together so
they're one city the economic
development corporation will be
releasing their fairy study within
before the first of the year and so I
can't talk about it but there's very
study will be making some significant
proposals about water transport and I'm
sorry that I can't give you more detail
but there it's their purview right now
but before the end of the air you will
hear a lot Joey
wait okay Joseph taluk with the MS red
graduate program you could wave a magic
wand over governor's island will would
be the result that's such an interest in
governor's island you know governor's
island with Leslie Koch a son with
governor's island I sort of called him
Gulliver she could the sleeping giant is
like so alive and desirable and the
question is is still is it still in co
it is it still birthing people are
loving the experience of going to
Governors Island I was talking to the
other day and she had like two years ago
three years ago is 50,000 two years ago
it was 200,000 people came in a summer
this summer it was 450,000 so maybe it
needs some time for it to settle in for
people to figure out what it means to
them and have new yorkers participate in
that discussion unless he's very intent
on getting the park built and often
that's a very good way to start it
provides an sort of armature for what
should happen later and so I think
that's a good a good example and I was
lucky to be involved in Battery Park
City and we fact built the little piece
of the Esplanade before anything else
and so maybe that's the best thing could
happen in terms of land use there are
lots of ideas but the more people who
come out to the island and actually see
it maybe that's how we get the best
ideas maybe it's not a good thing to
leap and make a decision I'm whether it
should be academic institution you know
there's a prohibition against
residential but if that's a good or bad
idea but I think it needs time to to
evolve a little bit more because it's so
special anybody who hasn't been out
there it's closed now but next summer
you got to go it's totally fun Amelia
hi my name is Emil and with ms redd my
questions about you were talking about
125th street and I was wondering for
that project if you work with a CDC or
you work with a Conservancy and I guess
I was just doing some research and I
don't really understand the difference
between for instance like the Bryant
Park Conservancy or the Empire vampire
CDC and it seems like the panning would
work with both of those types of
institutions do projects like the ones
you just described so there's not a
concern I mean we worked with multiple
agencies working on 125 street but did
you say Conservancy so did you
understand the question
and so the conservancy usually is about
both investing in public space and
maintaining that space the first thing
we want to see happen on 125th street is
to get the developments have happened
and to incentivize the entertainment and
cultural uses there in combination with
you know office and housing and
affordable housing and then as it
develops they do have a business
improvement district that actually is in
charge of maintaining the streetscape so
actually that's their Conservancy right
now but the goal is actually to foster
this development which will actually
embrace this cultural heritage and
that's the goal and I know didn't answer
your question completely but I'll give
it some more thought okay maybe you had
your hand up you're just going to be at
microphone or two seconds my name is
Mimi lava and at first I want to thank
you for the great presentation and I
have a question about what is your
vision for a Holland Tunnel and current
congestion there there is what the green
space which is unused and what is your
long a long term and short short term
solution for it oh that's really good
question for another Holland Tunnel is
under juris in terms of what should
happen for the transportation planning I
actually don't have a clue what should
happen with the I mean the congestion at
that tunnel and the lincoln tunnel is
really a problem about the number of
cars that are coming into the city and
that's the first thing we have to do is
to provide other and better ways to get
into the city but in terms of the
pattern of automobile how our
automobiles enter the tunnel is that
your question or is it land use
obviously I should say and ns2 we have a
problem with the jurisdiction it was
very much goes to be Sean's question the
FDR Drive and the West Side Highway
aren't in control of the city their
control of the state so integrating our
upland community our existing
communities to better integrate with the
waterfront has to deal with
communication with the state and getting
them to agree because it's terrible as
you have to go through this huge barrier
of a gigantic highway to get to the
water and there's not adequate
pedestrian passage across that highway
and so that whole area is really but you
know it's a good idea it's really
something the city city should study and
amount of study but come up with an
urban design plan to better make this a
better environment for pedestrians and
claim what we can that's what Janette
sadik-khan is done reclaim for
pedestrian use areas that have been
given over too much to the automobile so
that's an excellent idea and I'm going
to pursue that I promise do you think
should we should take another run at
congestion pricing it may not be called
congestion pricing movie another name
for it right there it has to happen sir
the back
hi my name is Richard I'm a alumni
architecture my question is regarding
the third Avenue Webster Avenue corridor
in the Bronx is there it I noticed
there's a high density of low-income
housing being concentrated there is
there an alternate transportation
solution toward to the metro-north for
those residents because I mean my having
lived in the Bronx I know the
metro-north is infrequent and it's
expensive especially for the people that
are being concentrated in that area and
that's it and they don't and it doesn't
run in the right direction and stopping
elfin as it should as part of our grant
that we just got from HUD will be
working with metro north and looking at
all the metro-north stops in the Bronx
do have it respond better and build
communities around it so we're just
going to begin the process of studying
that we just got the grant about two
weeks ago but you're right it really
doesn't serve the communities and the
way it should and certainly reverse
commuting as well have you considered
bringing back the third Avenue el as an
option we couldn't do if we wanted to
but no because I think the elevated
usually divided communities and what
happened along third Avenue is because
the L was there all the zoning was only
for auto-related uses for auto repair
shop and that really divided the east
and west sides of that community and so
I think it's really important to knit
that community and you and not have it
not have it divided yes it provided
transportation but it also made it a not
a desirable community to live in and
invest in so I hope our plan works okay
I'm Kate or from an assistant professor
here and I just wanted to say that that
you and your fellow commissioners have
done so much to transform each of your
different departments from within and
redefining the street like with Jeanette
and yourself using this sort of
pre-existing tool of zoning but in a
completely new way towards completely
new ends and I'm wondering with the the
new initiatives this incredibly
evocative work term of the sixth borough
and also with this sustainability
initiative and wondering if these kinds
of new future kind of trends have have
sparked a kind of conversation among the
departments of how the sort of
regulatory or governmental framework
would also need to evolve to address
these new kind of urban challenges which
seemed to me to be incredibly
interdisciplinary and interconnected we
actually do work together all the time
we work with a transportation department
the transfer not only the Transportation
Department but housing preservation and
development very interpret in in the
fresh program we were very close as I
mentioned with the Department of mendham
of Health and Mental Hygiene also the
department of design and construction
you've seen these new guidelines come
out active design guidelines each one of
these active design guidelines so
interesting you can look at a building
if the stairs are visible in a building
people are more likely to use them
there's so many ways that you can
increase activity and health of New
Yorkers by small design changes but this
was totally Department of design and
construction Department of Health
transportation and city planning and so
it's through the mayor he makes sure
that we all work together on all of
these projects so just to say an STD a
question they wouldn't be so successful
if there were just one department one
agency working on these challenges and
these opportunities it's because he has
us make sure that we all work together
and to solve this it's just it's a it's
a so the ethic of the administration you
can
you that if anybody's been to City Hall
you see everybody sits in a bullpen and
the mayor's desk is about this big and
then the deputy mayor's here and and he
will say what's going on about this
what's going on about that it's a very
it's that kind of administration it's
totally I'm totally lucky to be a part
of it but nobody is in their silos and
that makes all the difference and and
everybody's open to new ideas that's the
whole idea and that's why it's really
great having new deputy mayors because
they actually see it from a whole
different perspective I say what haven't
you done this and I say morrow and so
we're trying everything but out that
answers your question
it seems like you've been able to make a
lot of changes through special zoning
districts and my question is is the city
eventually going to be all special
zoning districts or is the 1961 zoning
resolution eventually going to reach the
end of its life span and that you notice
were almost 50 years out from it and the
1960s owning was only about 45 years
there's a good question I don't know we
keep thinking there used to be this rule
no more special districts but then
sometime we have a particular zoning we
couldn't have done the High Line without
the special district for the transfer
and we couldn't have had a stoning bonus
for the Arts in one hundred and twenty
fifth street without special district in
Coney Island that's really special so we
have fun I don't know as we've fallen
because the zoning our zoning toolbox
they're like four things in it and now
we have about 20 things and we don't
have enough tools in the toolbox without
and maybe we'll have more things in our
toolbox that we can use for another
zoning that so third Avenue Webster
Avenue are not special districts it
sounds to make us not special district
so you're right it should be used
carefully and not that every district is
special but we've been trying to
fine-tune each one of these places so
that their unique and that's why we fall
into special district it's a little bit
harder to enforce and that's the that's
the that's the problem with the special
districts of the Department of Buildings
then it's given you know the
responsibility of enforcing the zoning
and they have a different every district
has a different rule so you're right we
shouldn't use it all the time but we do
Oh a new zoning resolution well you know
when I first got this job I can't tell
you how many people said you have to do
comprehensive plan the whole city and I
knew if ever did that I would never do
anything else and it would be out of
date by the time I finished it and then
are doing a new zoning resolution which
you've seen but a lot of people haven't
seen it's this horrible thing and we
actually have to reprint the whole thing
this year because we were sued because
the word development for us means
something new development and
development with the courts ruled it
only meant a new development so
everywhere in the zoning resolution the
development is mentioned we had to
change the whole thing so as cookers
like seven million times and just the
process of doing that has been so doing
into his own and gristle this you're
right it should be done and my successor
just tell him do it be great
well often you have to have a
combination of the two things but we
only have one thing that we do at City
Planning so we have usually Sony with or
you could only use it for like two
different things so we use it for a
hundred different things it's true we
try to use it for everything for
incentivising who would have ever
thought zoning couldn't incentivize
healthy food choices so we're trying to
expand the use of zoning as a tool to
make a to make a better City but they're
they're also coupled with other
incentives so offer insistently in the
fresh program they're also financial
incentives to create a an incentive for
a new grocery store so in fact there
should be multiple incentive so I no
zoning best and so we use that as a tool
but always in combination with other
agencies incentives so HPD as its own
multiple programs for affordable housing
when we pair those with zoning the
inclusionary zoning only works this big
bonus used to be only twenty percent of
twenty percent like four percent
affordable housing we got it to twenty
percent by allowing HPD's programs to be
used in combination with the bonus so
zoning alone is not enough so just as a
question before it's about the
partnership of agencies to actually make
you know 10 1 equals 5 so using the
other incentives that other agencies
bring to bear has really born a lot of
fruit and so it's a really good question
thanks a lot of questions in the front
of that those you
via zone in question I'm not sure um the
really large tower that nyu wants to
build on bleecker street and i don't
mean this to open up the whole you know
can of worms on that i'm just wondering
if you could use it as an example to
explain the difference of the spectrum
of development versus maintaining
neighborhoods do you understand that I
understand but ok the beekman the the
proposed tower as part of the nyu and
that doesn't go it's not going through
zoning it's actually as of right and it
just has to go through through landmarks
but i think your question is
neighborhood character versus
development and as I steins best the
balance and that's what the public
process you know is about because you
know when we started the Greenpoint
Williamsburg rezoning that was very
tough for that community we saw it as a
city as a whole green poor williamsburg
waterfront was virtually abandoned but
we at city when you were growing and
that was an opportunity for 10,000 units
of housing if it was pretty tall but it
was this very low scale beautiful
community just would have been zoned for
much taller and it took years of working
with them to say okay we will protect
and freeze the height in Greenpoint
especially Greenpoint in exchange for
development on the waterfront we'll make
sure as a varied skyline each developer
will have to build his piece of the
water's edge it won't get a full height
muscles affordable housing but it took a
long time for that negotiation to
balance because these are tall towers in
a very low scale community and there
were benefits you know they had chained
there was a chain-link fence thing they
couldn't get to the waterfront but they
participated in the design of a design
of whole waterfront two benches the
railing and so it was a very iterative
process so it was balanced there
sometimes just too much but the
community will not let it happen because
in men there say
and their representative elected
official without a vote for it or
against it so if you haven't done your
job about building consensus it's really
not going to happen so that's why I'm
very I'm very big fan of this public
process issue I mean in terms of NYU but
also you know I'm University here at
Columbia Fordham is needing to grow this
issue of institutional growth how little
do you think that is this point in the
city's history so that's a really good
question we actually had a little
discussion about it you're about it
beforehand our the intellectual capacity
of the city is it's come it's because
its competitiveness if we don't
capitalize on the intellectual growth in
New York City and foster institutional
expansion both hospital and university
expansion we will be bypassed by other
cities and nothing could be really more
important and seeing Columbia's growth
is absolutely essential and I was
thrilled to have displayed a small role
in that process because that's how the
city grows it's one of the unique ways
that we are competitive and so
institution fostering the institutional
groves I say both hospital and
university is is our future because
intellectual capital of the city is so
important to compete in the back green
sweater
hi my name is ping I'm an architect with
kpf so I've been watching the designs
for Hudson Yards get wackier and wackier
thanks 40 way to think anyway he's wacky
wacky tabacky my question is about the
MTA and I was wondering how City
Planning is working with the MTA to
ensure that the success of all these
visions you have for the city because
the nature of your partnership with the
MTA is kind of opaque you're absolutely
right it's not it's not easy they have a
mission and they you know if they have
to be reminded over and over again that
what happens above ground is critical to
the economic value of this area so
that's New York's Development
Corporation is in charge of that area
and we are working incredibly closely
with them to make sure that that park
and Boulevard is the best that it can
possibly be because that's the identity
of that neighborhood MTA sees that
neighborhood from way down like you know
6,000 feet below below grade and they
need their vet structures and they want
this to be on time and on budget and the
same time the above grade with the
streetscape is like it's absolutely
critical to the city and its economic
value so you can understand they're just
sitting there focus we're interested in
our focus so it's a it's a constant
conversation let us put it that way
what are the low-hanging fruits that
you've done in New York City that other
municipalities could replicate in there
with all their problems that they may
have let say that again the low-hanging
fruit where the low-hanging fruits that
you've accomplished here in New York
that other cities could grab hold of the
easily transform their cities well
that's a big question so we did there
I'm not gonna go through all 104
rezoning but that was you know if it
transit-oriented grows is the first
that's something that's very important
but focusing on the street and sidewalk
in the street it's how everybody judges
everything you know I've used this
phrase but I think it's right is that
you know we're a scope of our ambitions
it's like a Robert Moses scale but we
judge ourselves by jane jacobs standards
and in the end that's what we have to do
and i think that's what you know you
have to have you have to have ambitious
plans but if they don't have any
relationship to the pedestrian and how
people feel when they walk down the
street they totally failed so i think
those are the two principles it was like
broad scale you know trans stories get
people out of their cars give them
options so that's very important give
them alternatives to the automobile
that's so important you know the bike
lanes I'm the bike lanes the tree-lined
streets car share all of these things
that you know often people use that car
like once a week to do a big shopping or
take the kid to hockey game or like you
don't need to do that you've CarShare us
around so make give people options to
get out of their cars focus on the focus
on the pedestrian focus on the biking is
really important to the city it just
makes the city feel connected and young
people are out of their boxes of their
cars you know you go to Copenhagen
switch the social it's very sociable
city because people are in that confined
steel box of the car so biking and
especially when all of these bike lanes
get connected that's going to change the
city and if we get bike share that
fabulous that's um so all of those
things look at include okay probably a
couple more Olympia you had a question
earlier
so about your successor so we are in our
third term and i believe the Bloomberg
administration has started a lot of
great projects there is always pays to
improve so that's why we are around the
nonprofit and but you are doing you know
a lot of great initiatives especially in
terms of you know sustainable Urban
Development but again as it happened to
the previous administration the next
person who is going to come they're
going to have their own agenda and
priorities and and so it's a bit of a
silly question mind because I would say
what do you want this to try to save for
sure from all the things that study what
are they because you know in-depth how
the city has been changing in the past
few years and what do you believe has
been the most important operations that
you achieved in this administration and
that they're vulnerable and and so that
we should work around them and you know
make them stronger and make sure that
they continue that's really that's a
really good question because the mayor
says we want to get enough done they
can't be undone so we don't want to be
undone I think one of the legacies is
going to be these quality public open
spaces I think the High Line and
protecting the High Line both section 1
and section 2 and section 3 if we get it
and the East River waterfront south
south of south and north of the South
Street Seaport these legacy public
spaces are really important to the city
so making sure that subsequent
administration's takes care of them and
prioritizes them because very quickly
you know the High Line could be you know
allow access all along and it could
become a street could become a retail
street if it's not doesn't have a
vigilant you know community that says no
this is a this is a garden in the skies
a park in the sky it's not a retail
street you know you have to protect it
so there you know the public opens
basically really really really important
and you know always focusing the
development on transit areas don't let
development go out in areas where it
doesn't belong and as I say again again
preserving the character of
neighborhoods and don't let them get
don't people develop them because I have
to admit it's very unique to work for a
mayor like Mike Bloomberg because when
yes you know there's benefits of having
financial resources so nobody owes
anybody anything and I've asked him you
know lots of time saying mayor what do
you think I should do about this and he
always says do what you think is the
right thing to do no you know that's
really incredible so just saying that's
great well I think we can only do one
more question up there I'm Meredith
Palmer I'm an art dealer and also a
concerned citizen I'm really impressed
with all you've been doing and I
recently the moma had the museum modern
art had a show of about the waterfront
lower waterfront and I was really quite
concerned after seeing that and I wonder
how I mean the fact that we're going to
lose a lot of the lower waterfront with
global warming and other factors and I'm
wondering how an exhibition like that
figures into your thinking if it has an
effect and also whether you can talk a
little bit more about the public process
that you go through maybe on a project
like that or on the issue of the
waterfront and how could you just walk
us through sort of how you engage the
public on something so important is that
on the waterfront the rising currents
show was fantastic I'm sure a lot of
people here saw it I was on the jury for
it and I just did a panel on it about a
week ago and actually influenced our
waterfront plan very much because it's
clear from that exhibit that the issues
of not just sea level rise but the real
issue of storm surge and the velocity of
storm surge is the vulnerable makes a
city very vulnerable and princess the
bulkheads that we built a battery park
city is probably the worst thing you can
do because that velocity hits the
bulkhead and son not good so will we
have advocated in the plan is softening
the edge a one enhancing wetlands not
only wetland habitats but marine
habitats in fact one of the best ways
and you saw it in oyster texture one of
the best ways of actually slowing down
that
velocity of the storm surge is soo
creating reefs and governors island
actually just lowered the harbor school
lower their first reef into the into the
harbor about two weeks ago so we
understand those issues very much both
sea-level rise and storm surge so you'll
see and our waterfront recommendations
which is on our website that that's very
much taken into consideration also in
terms of how you design the water's edge
we are advocating not only soft edge but
where there's a walkway that we use
riprap instead so all of these actually
feed into the into the new waterfront
plan recommendations and we'll still
getting feedback on them so we won't
finalize them until the end of the year
but the public process was very strong
in fact we began outreach with each one
we have borough offices with the borough
office is starting last winter and going
to each community about their issues on
each one of the 22 reaches of the
waterfront and then this spring and
summer we held workshops in each borough
but also to do with we call the blue
network the sixth borough we held
separate workshops on those and the
metropolitan waterfront alliance was
sort of an umbrella for all of the small
groups I don't have doin swimmers I did
another ocean swimmers know people who
wrote actually row boats they felt that
they were being left out there's so many
constituents for the water and the
people who work on the water they said
like you know I always say like how many
people you know go birding how many
people work on the water there were so
many constituencies passionate
knowledgeable constituencies for the
water that we've engaged them it
continues through the through web but
all of these constituencies are now part
of one huge very strong voice advocating
for their different interests on the
waterfront so it's been really
remarkable it was my biggest worry
frankly is that we wouldn't be able to
engage the public at large in this plan
and it's feeling it's really really
feeling great
please thanks well on behalf of Mark
Wiggly and the entire University thank
you very much for taking time out of
your incredibly